[Music]
so you're lehman brothers in late 2007.
now most people today have heard of the
name lehman brothers before but few
understand just how much of a behemoth
lehman was at the time you had 639
billion dollars in assets which put
lehman brothers as the biggest
bankruptcy ever by a very large margin
making companies like enron look rather
pathetic that made you the fourth
largest investment bank in the us
alongside names like goldman sachs and
merrill lynch
25 000 people worked for you all over
the world some of wall street's
brightest minds work for you and you
have been in business for more than 150
years
basically you were wall street royalty
and anyone who wants to get into
investment banking take their company
public or sell stock knew that lehman
brothers was the bank to go to and in
2007 you were in your prime you had just
come out of your biggest and best year
yet with record-breaking profits and
nothing but dollar signs in your future
your stock price was at the highest it's
ever been and you were raking in 19
billion dollars in revenue just that
year
it seemed like there was nowhere to go
but up
37 points or so apple shares are just
getting hammered this morning we're down
by between three and four and a half
down 21
because we're now down 43
what in the world is happening on wall
street two-year no yields
lehman brothers is going bankrupt
but then on monday september 15 2008 the
world wakes up to the total collapse of
lehman brothers
the investment bank that was far too big
to fail files for bankruptcy at 2am on a
monday morning marking it as the worst
business failure in u.s history and
almost instantly lehman brothers brings
the whole world down with it say a lot
of their customers are freaked out
pressure uh yahoo down eight and a half
percent cisco six and a half percent
down nine percent today the zetra dax
over in frankfurt it's down by nine
percent
but why
and who was lehman
lehman brothers suffering a spectacular
downfall it's stock at one point this
year sold for 67 a share right now it's
trading at just three dollars 65 cents a
share lehman brothers a 158 year old
firm filed
page report 15 months in the making
brothers in the beginning of the worst
financial crisis
karen this is absolutely stunning wall
street has seen very very few days like
this to do what lehman brothers did they
use a lot of quantitative finance
quantitative finance is basically using
math and data science to analyze things
like stocks in the stock market it's
what every major investment bank on wall
street uses to manage their investment
portfolios the people that do this are
called quants and they make very good
money 117 000 a year on average to be
exact and if you want to break into this
very high paying field that's where
brilliant comes in
brilliant is a website and app that
offers interactive courses in math and
science which includes their course on
math or quantitative finance what makes
brilliant different from everything else
is that it's built off of a very simple
principle you learn best by doing not
through lectures not through repetition
and not by doing odd number exercises in
a textbook that's why with brilliant you
get to jump right into solving problems
while being coach bit by bit before you
even realize it you've learned a
fundamental concept in stem you get
instant feedback along the way so you
can improve as fast as possible and
there aren't any tests or grades either
just pick a topic you're curious about
and get started they even have an entire
learning path dedicated to probability
statistics and finance to help you build
up to quantitative finance and it ends
with a course on cryptocurrencies where
you learn how cryptographic primitives
power the blockchain and digital
currencies
we live in the easiest time in human
history to move up the social ladder but
the only way you're going to do that is
through self-education and to get
started on your self-education brilliant
is giving you guys 20 off when you go to
brilliant.org tram with the link below
that's brilliant.org jaytran to sign up
for free and get 20 off thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video
there are some who see memorial day as
just a welcome excuse for a barbecue
at shearson lehman brothers however we
see it as the day to remember those who
are part of the family named americans
and who in defense of the family gave of
themselves on battlefields and beaches
in the skies and on the seas
let them hear the bells
let freedom ring
like the name suggests lehman brothers
was started by the lehman brothers but
it didn't start out as a bank at all
it was the 1840s and henry lehman had
just arrived in america from germany he
became a door-to-door salesman in
alabama and eventually saved up enough
money to open up a store that stole dry
goods and other small consumer goods one
by one his two brothers emanuel and
mayor joined him giving rise to lehman
brothers in 1850
at the time alabama was a cotton farming
states and the lehman brothers quickly
started accepting cotton as a method of
payment for goods in their store they
would then sell that con to different
buyers which eventually became a
business of its own with all the new
connections they were making between
cotton farmers and cotton buyers the
lehman brothers abandoned the idea of a
grocery store and went full time into
selling cotton over time they basically
became cotton brokers they connected
farmers with buyers and got a fee for
their services
and then in 1855 the original brother
henry died of yellow fever so the two
remaining brothers moved to new york to
open up an office there they helped set
up the new york cotton exchange and
pretty soon they were brokering the sale
of a lot of other commodities too that
continued for more than 50 years and
then they started moving away from
commodities to more of investment
banking as we know them today
[Music]
by 1906 you as lehman brothers were
doing pretty well for yourself in the
commodities trade you were making so
many new contacts and building your
network to the point where eventually
you saw that the real money was in real
finance not brokering commodity sales so
you took the skills you learned from
over half a century of being the
middleman for commodity sales and
applied that to a new trade underwriting
underwriting is fancy financial jargon
for when you act as the middlemen for
companies that want to go public when a
company wants to go public and sell
their shares on the stock market they
want some kind of guarantee that their
shares are going to sell for a certain
price on the other hand the people
buying the shares want to make sure it's
a legit company with no skeletons in the
closet they don't want to get dumped on
by company executives that just want to
cash outs that's where the underwriters
come in they come over the books the
numbers they make sure all the
regulatory requirements are met they
check with institutional investors to
gauge their interest in the stock and
then they set the initial price for the
stock to be sold at along with
guaranteeing that a specific number of
shares would be sold all for a
commission that way hopefully the
company wins the underwriters win and
the people who buy the stock win
as the underwriters if you're right you
make a lot of money if you're wrong
about the company however you're going
to lose out on a ton of money this was
lehman brothers first entry into the
world of high finance and they were very
good at it because you already had a lot
of money from commodities to back you up
you could take chances on smaller
riskier businesses other banks wouldn't
touch with a six foot pole and your risk
often paid out one of the industries you
branched into was retail where you were
the underwriter for future mega
retailers like woolworths studebaker and
macy's
over and over again you move into a new
industry and get lucky with companies
that were turned into future major
successes you underwrote paramount and
fox in the movie business you branch
into electronics companies automakers
and at least a dozen other niches with a
healthy amount of risk taking you manage
to make it through and profit from
suddenly worse crises to hit the earth
the civil war railroad disasters world
war 1 world war ii the stock market
crashed in 1929 and the great depression
it fast forward all the way to 1994 and
lehman brothers was bought for 360
million dollars by american express a
company that has started as a grocery
store had become one of the most
valuable financial firms in america
eventually you were spun off from
american express into an independent
privately managed investment bank which
is where the story of the lehman
brothers we know today really starts to
suck the new and improved lehman
brothers off on the right foot a
lifelong employee named richard fold was
appointed to ceo richard or dick started
working at lehman brothers in 1966 when
he was only 20 years old then in 1993 he
was appointed to the ceo of the company
after nearly three decades with the firm
his number one goal to absolutely kill
the competition he wanted to take lehman
brothers to the top and he did it by
borrowing a ton of money and taking on
massive risks to play the market himself
his strategy was so successful that he
ended up being the longest serving ceo
on wall street and expanded lehman
brothers into europe and the rest of the
world under dictful's guidance lehman
brothers became the best of the best
some people see the sunset as the end of
the day
others see it as the beginning of an
evening
we however see it as the start of a new
day in hong kong singapore and tokyo
expanding the horizons
is capitalism at its best
and why you'll never look at a sunset
quite the same again
in the early 2000s the real estate
market in the u.s and around the world
was booming this was because of low
interest rates and a lot of incentives
from the governments with even the
president of the united states telling
everyone they should be owning homes
owning a home lies at the heart of the
american dream home is a foundation for
families and a source of stability for
communities it serves as the foundation
of many americans financial security
more and more people started buying
houses on mortgages because it was so
cheap and easy to get into you didn't
even need to put much money down so
prices started skyrocketing which led to
people buying even more homes and banks
issuing more mortgages what resulted
were ninja loans mortgages to anyone and
everyone with no income no job no assets
also known as subprime mortgages if
people ended up not paying back their
mortgage well no problem they could just
take back the house and resell it right
away since there was so much demand and
since these mortgages were so profitable
the banks who would issue these
mortgages would then resell that
mortgage to a bigger investment bank for
our profits for a while it seemed like
everyone was making more and more money
and that's where lehman brothers came
into this equation one of the ways
lehman brothers got involved in real
estate was through these mortgage-backed
securities but don't let this financial
jargon fool you behind all the vague
terms it was actually pretty simple
because the people who got a mortgage
would be paying it off for the next 10
years or more if you're an institutional
investor think pension funds retirement
funds that's pretty attractive in theory
mortgages gave you consistent
predictable safe cash flow that was the
pitch so investment banks like lehman
bought thousands of mortgages from the
smaller banks that issued them they
would then package a bunch of mortgages
together and then resold them as a
mortgage-backed security pension funds
retirement funds and other institutional
investors would then buy them because
again it gave them consistent
predictable save cash flow this business
was so lucrative that you just couldn't
help yourself and at one point you own
76 billion dollars worth of mortgages
all over the us
but it didn't stop there not only was
lehman neck deep in the mortgage-backed
security craze you even borrowed a ton
of money to start building commercial
properties yourself like hotels and
residential complexes in the us and all
over the world by 2007 you were the
biggest mortgage underwriter in the us
owning more than 22 billion dollars in
real estate it got to the point where
you had over 600 billion dollars in
assets with only 7 billion dollars in
cash and it was working lehman brothers
shares were at an all-time high of 86
with a market cap of 60 billion your
risky investments were obviously working
and all the other banks that were too
scared to do the same as you were gonna
get left in the dust and it would have
kept working if those bad mortgages
didn't make up your entire foundation
[Applause]
[Music]
the pessimist sees the glass as half
empty
the optimist sees the glass as half full
we however see it as a way to quench
your thirst
boil an egg
or
make something grow
seeing the possibilities
is capitalism at its best
and why you'll never look at a glass of
water
quite the same again
just as you hit your prime in 2007
something unexpected happened mortgage
interest rates went back up which meant
it now costs a lot more money to get a
mortgage so the demand for house is
nosedived and with it the demand for
mortgages also nosedived that would have
been manageable if the people who
already bought houses kept paying their
mortgage but there was another problem
most of the mortgages especially the
subprime ones were set at an adjustable
interest rate so as interest rates went
up the same people making the same
income would have to pay a much higher
monthly payment so the people with no
income no job and no assets but had a
mortgage got squeezed and foreclosed on
this set off a chain reaction demand for
houses plummeted so the houses that got
foreclosed on sat empty with no buyers
otherwise lehman brothers owed 44
dollars for every one dollar they had or
in other words lehman had a 1 to 44
leverage ratio while most investment
banks had a ratio of only around 1 to 20
or 1 to the low 30s which was still
insane but if any investment bank were
to fall first it would be lehman
how much of my assets should be in cash
how do i know when my investments are
working for me
how can the investment that was right
for my neighbor not be right for me
the more serious you are as an investor
the more questions you have to ask
so if you've been asking yourself these
questions talk with us
and invest your time before you invest
your money shearson lehman american
express and the serious investor minds
over money
2008 got off to a really bad start when
one of your biggest competitors bear
stearns crashed and burned first they
were eventually bought out by jp morgan
with the help of the federal reserve but
if you were worried before you were in
full panic mode now
by september 2008 lehman reported a
third quarter loss of almost 4 billion
dollars and your stock experiences a
free fall to 7 a share from its 86
dollar high and your best hope a buyout
or bailouts even though you had assets
worth more than your debt no one wanted
to buy real estate anymore so those
assets were worth nothing by friday
september 12 2008 lehman was losing 8
million dollars a minute so the u.s
treasury secretary henry paulsen calls a
meeting with all of america's leading
bank executives the masters of the
universe as they were known as he told
everyone that the u.s government would
not be doing anything to bail out lehman
brothers and it would be up to these
banks to decide your future the same
banks dick full so desperately wanted to
destroy
at the time you weren't too worried you
were lehman brothers after all the
fourth biggest investment bank in the us
obviously someone a company or the
government would come to your rescue
they couldn't afford to let you go under
you were too big to fail so when bank of
america expressed interest in buying you
out things started to look bright again
but not long after one of your other
competitors merrill lynch was also in
trouble and since they had not sunk so
deep into the real estate black hole
merrill lynch was a much more attractive
choice for bank of america to buy the
lehman brothers so bank of america
bought merrill lynch for 50 billion
dollars
by sunday time was running out your
final hope or clay's bank who came in on
sunday with big promises of making all
your worries go away in exchange for a
buyout by sunday afternoon you were
close to making a deal but then out of
nowhere the financial services authority
in the uk where barclays was from
cancelled the whole thing and your last
hope vanished by sunday evening lehman
knew their case was hopeless
where do you want to be in five years
i had an old studebaker truck and 300
when i started this company
in a few years my sons will be ready to
take over and then i'd like to
i never told anybody this uh
i want to live in paris and go to
cooking school
hey
that's what i want to do will i have the
money to do it
you can get there from here
with sirson lehman brothers
with no plan c your bankruptcy lawyers
were called in on sunday evening the
lawyers were through the dead of the
knights and just before 2 am on monday
september 15 2008 they sent the email to
file lehman brothers for bankruptcy
after 158 years the behemoth was no more
where do you want to be in 20 years
well my father worked for the same
company for 39 years
he got two weeks vacation but we never
traveled far
he was saving to put three kids through
college at 65 he retired
at 67
he died
how can i invest so that after my kids
graduate i can enjoy the second half of
my life
you can get there from here
the impact of lima's collapse affected
the world like nothing else before its
the fact that a business so big so
respected so valuable could crash and
burn like that left companies all over
the us in a panic for all they knew they
could be next trust in the us markets
was suddenly non-existent and the
economy was going to be paying for it
much sooner than expected everyone was
calling their banks and financial
advisors non-stop
some of the biggest corporations were
suddenly confessing that they didn't
have enough money to pay their employees
or fund their operating costs
none of the banks around the world were
confident enough to lend to each other
the whole financial industry basically
came to a standstill and just two days
after declaring bankruptcy barclays bank
bought most of the assets they wanted
from lehman brothers in the first place
and the lehman brothers employees
and dick fold wall street's golden boy
was suddenly unemployed the 2008
financial crisis had finally arrived and
it was all triggered by lehman brothers
today dick fold the former ceo of lehman
brothers owns a company offering
consulting services to high net worth
clients
[Music]
lehman brothers has become the scapegoat
for the 2008 financial crisis but the
truth is most of wall street was doing
the same thing lehman was doing but they
just didn't fall first see there are two
sides to every hyper successful person
what they tell the general public about
their success it's all about hard work
consistency perseverance and what they
actually think and do behind closed
doors when the cameras are off like
riding the hype of toxic mortgage-backed
securities because i want to reach in
rip out their heart and eat it before
they die the problem is you're never
going to learn about how they actually
operate unless you're already in
successful circles because it's not
politically correct not that i want to
hurt him don't get that please cause
that's just not who i am
i am soft i'm lovable because if the
elite did admit how they actually
thought they would be pillows and sent
to the guillotine or if your dick fold
you end up being the scapegoat in front
of the entire country i take full
responsibility
for the decisions that i made
and for the actions
that i took that's why you're never
gonna learn the stuff in business school
you're never going to learn the stuff
from your friends and family but you
will learn it here in our new
feature-length 40-minute plus
documentaries breaking down how the
world really works in all its
machiavellian glory but the thing is i
don't want to get cancelled or
scapegoated like dick fold so we're not
going to be releasing these to the
public all you have to do if you want to
get this education that they will never
teach you in business school is click
the join button below right next to the
subscribe button if you don't see the
button there's a link in the video
description below once you sign up
you'll get exclusive access to the first
documentary coming out in a few days on
monsanto the company that owns the
world's food supply or you'll get access
immediately if it's already up by the
time you're watching this and unlike an
mba i'm not going to charge you 55 000
to 161 thousand dollars to learn this
stuff note just five dollars a month for
longer documentaries of the same videos
you love that you will not be able to
see anywhere else and this five dollars
a month is just to cover the cost to
produce these videos
give it a try for a month and if you
don't think this knowledge is worth it
pause the video and click the join
button below right now